[موسيقى]
مودعون خسروا اموالهم
فاقتحموا المصارف لتحصيل ودائعهم
حملوا المسؤوليه لما سموه تحالفا سياسيا
ماليا رقم في رايهم فسادا استفاده من
قانون السريه المصرفيه بشكل اساسي
نبهتنا كذا مره الى هذا الموضوع ولا تهرب
الضريبه كرم الرئاسه
البرلمان شهدت محاولات تعديل القانون
مخاضا عسيرا على مدى اكثر من عامين وبعدها
الطره النواب لاقرار الصيغه المعدله تلبيه
لمطالب الجهات الدوليه المانحه وتقول
السلطات الرسميه ان التعديلات ستسمح
بتوسيع دائره المحاسبه
هذا الموضوع بيفتح مجهله للسلطه القضائي
او للسلطه
باي موضوع تبيض اموال او تهب طبيب انا
توصل له وتشوف كيف بدها تعالج الموضوع
ايجابيات التعديل لم تلغي وفق خبراء
حقوقيين اثر التدخلات السياسيه التي حدث
برايهم من الجرعه الاصلاحيه في القانون
اسيما بنسبه للصلاحيات الممنوحه للقضاء ما
سيقلص الشفافيه المطلوبه القضاء اليوم لو
اخذت صلاحيته في شك بانه يستطيع القضاء
اللبناني بان يقوم بمهامه بشكل كامل
لاجراء المحاسبه طالما ان العلاقه بين
السياسه والقضاء في لبنان هي علاقه غير
صحيه
السريه المصرفيه كانت احد العوائق امام
محاولات للتدقيق الجنائي في حسابات المصرف
المركزي والمؤسسات العامه اثر التعاقد
السلطات مع شركه دوليه لم تنجز مهمتها حتى
الان
لطالما قيل ان الفساد في لبنان مقاونا
ورغم تعديل قانون السريه المصرفيه ما زال
جهه سياسيه وحقوقيه تشكك في ايدي ذلك الى
كشف الفاسدين ومحاسبتهم في ظل ما يصفونه
بتحكم السلطه السياسيه بمفاصل الدوله كافه
كاترين حنا الجزيره بيروت